pas à hâter raté attention vient à
toucher qu'un super attention tu va
démolir ma boutique
mais enfin tu marach juste au moment où
j'allais gagner ma bataille cédé 12 mois
mais quel genre de batailles faisais tu
tu ne devine pas regarde
attention au poing dans la figure
sinon ça va lui faire froid dans le coup
je ne dois pas à toujours vous êtes là
vous avez compris vous de quelle
bataille il s'agit c'est quelque chose
que l'on ramasse que l'on met en boule
que l'on se jette qui ne fait pas trop
mal quand on le reçoit et qui fait froid
dans le coup
vous devinez moi pas beaucoup de
recherches julie une bataille de glace
aux hanches mois mais non la glace ou
dans choix voyons c'est ça se mange et
c'est bien trop bon pour qu'on se bat
avec et j'ai bien une idée mais c'est
pas possible dans l'île aux enfants
peut-il 1 toujours propre tu vas me
trouvais ridicule énorme et nous va dire
ben à une bataille de boules de neige
mais oui c'est ça une bataille de boules
de neige mais voyons quasi veille a pas
de neige dans l'île aux enfants
ah non mais il va bientôt y en avoir
j'attends un colis de boules de neige de
poules donné écoute
j'ai mon cousin albéric qui habite dans
la grande montagne qui m'envoie un colis
le colis doit arriver aujourd'hui
alors j'attends le facteur colis de
boules de neige par bateau mon pauvre
casimir je crains bien que tu sois des
bons françois aubart y envoyer il
m'arrive eu une aventure incroyable
c'est épouvantable et qu'on écoute tout
à l'heure je passais sur le port juste
après l'arrivée du bateau quant à des
maranatha el hindi et françois dit vous
n'ayez pas apporté ce colis au jardin
l'île aux enfants
moi comme un idiot j'accepte il me lance
en disant c'est un colis boule de neige
j'ai à peine le temps de revenir de la
surprise j'attrape le carton au vol il
craque
mais voilà et voilà je suis trompé et en
plus en plus avec l'eau lancre de
l'adresse était complètement effacés ce
qui fait que j'ai même pas pu voir le
nom de l'imbécile qui s'est fait envoyer
un colis de boules de neige aux jardins
sans même réfléchir que la neige allait
fondre d'abord tu vraiment qui a pu
avoir par deux émirs et donc tu étais
pas en train d'attendre les colis par
hasard moi non non pas du tout tu tu es
sûr donc je suis venu là simplement pour
répéter ma danse avec julie n'est ce pas
où va répéter justement à bord
d'ailleurs ce qui nous dérange je les
attends je vous dérange
bon ben écoutez je pars mais changer et
celui qui s'est fait envoyer un colis de
boules de neige et je le retrouverai
s'il est à lui retrouvera bon break
allait musica
[Musique]
ouah
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]